the lord of the rings trilogy has become
so ingrained in popular culture that
it's difficult to imagine how it might
have looked with a different cast but
several notable actors turned down big
roles here are some of the names who
could have resided in middle earth
according to reports sean connery was
offered the role of gandalf before it
went to ian mckellen peter jackson was
apparently so keen on landing the former
bond actor that he convinced newline to
offer connery a 15 slice of the box
office takings plus a 30 million dollar
pay packet the lord of the rings trilogy
made just shy of 3 billion dollars
worldwide so it was a pretty costly
decision especially when you consider
the fact that connery went on to star in
the career ending the league of
extraordinary gentlemen instead so why
did the iconic scott turn down the
chance to play tolkien's most famous
wizard
ah i'll take swords for 400.
in 2012 a retired connery admitted that
he said no to the lord of the rings
because he just couldn't get his head
around the sprawling story the actor
said i read the book i read the script i
saw the movie i still don't understand
it
ian mckellen i believe is marvellous in
it when mckellen was asked about
jackson's pursuit of connery during an
interview with total film he joked that
the films would have been quote very
different had connery chosen to take on
the role saying
gandalf would have come from scotland
for a start you shall not parsh doesn't
have quite the same ring to it does it
stay back if you value your life
christopher plummer grew up reading the
lord of the rings and has admitted to
being a huge fan of tolkien's world but
he still chose to turn down the
opportunity to play gandalf when peter
jackson came calling years later the
actor revealed that he had an issue with
the level of commitment required for
plummer spending three years in new
zealand at his age just wasn't an option
he explained to conan o'brien i thought
there are other countries i'd also like
to visit before i croak he added that
the quote absolutely marvelous ian
mckellen brought a warmth to the wizard
that he himself may not have been able
to produce i might have been a little
cold and imperious plummer has still
done some memorable work since passing
on rings not that he had anything left
to prove after carving out his
illustrious career he was nominated for
a primetime emmy for playing cardinal
bernard law in the catholic church abuse
drama our fathers in 2005 and in 2012 he
scooped up his first academy award
triumphing in the best supporting actor
category for beginners his win made him
the oldest actor to take home a
competitive oscar plummer almost beat
his own record in 2018 when he was
nominated for all the money in the world
a role he famously took over for a
scandal hit kevin spacey at the last
minute
but he was beaten by sam rockwell for
three billboards outside ebbing missouri
peter jackson is said to have attempted
to convince daniel day-lewis to take on
the role of aragorn on numerous
occasions supposedly the three-time best
actor winner repeatedly spurned his
advances according to the one ring which
had the inside track on all things the
lord of the rings back when the trilogy
was still in development in october 1999
a source told the tolkien fan site that
producers have made one final push to
get day lewis on board stating ddl has
been offered the aragorn role again he
has been offered the middle earth to
take the role the producers think he'll
say no again but they don't want to miss
the chance to try him
day-lewis addressed the long-running
aragorn rumors over a decade later
confirming that he was indeed offered
the part speaking to mtv's josh horowitz
in 2009 the notoriously picky method
actor said that he rejected the role
because big franchise films just aren't
his bag he explained they can be
fantastically entertaining for the
people who love to see them but it's not
for me if i found myself working on a
film and during the course of that work
i was bored because i didn't really know
what the hell i was involved in i would
find that infinitely demoralizing and it
might well make me decide to pack my
bags
day lewis retired from acting in 2017
the idea of nicholas cage playing
aragorn might sound like nightmare fuel
but believe it or not this almost came
to pass
cage was a headliner at the time fresh
off starring roles in conair face-off
and snake eyes
no
yes no come on this is not fair man come
on call the cop
taking the lead in a big budget epic
like the lord of the rings would have
been the next logical step for him but
he was forced to turn down peter
jackson's offer because he had quote
family obligations that he couldn't
ignore it wasn't the only huge role he
passed on either cage also said no to
the matrix the actor said both are great
movies but they both shot for great
quantities of time i mean years
australia was the matrix and new zealand
was the lord of the rings
cage expanded on his explanation during
a 2015 interview with newsweek where he
said of the lord of the rings there were
different things going on in my life at
the time that precluded me from being
able to travel and be away from home for
three years
he has absolutely no regrets however
saying i get to enjoy the movies as an
audience member because i don't watch my
own movies had his schedule been
different perhaps the state of his
career today would be different too for
better or worse cage was unable to take
the part
and we're left wondering what bizarre
accent he might have given the future
king of gondor
by the time new zealand native russell
crowe was approached about the aragorn
vacancy the lord of the rings budget was
starting to look a little stretched they
didn't have enough cash to give crow a
suitable upfront fee so producers
offered him a percentage of the takings
instead it wasn't enough to tempt him
though years later crow conceded that it
would have been a risk well worth taking
in 2011 the actor delivered a lecture
about his career in the business to film
students at england's durham university
according to the telegraph crowe talked
about turning down the aragorn role
joking that he wouldn't have needed to
do paid appearances had he agreed to
newline's offer of 10
of the lord of the rings prophets so why
didn't he crow didn't reveal the
reasoning behind his costly decision
until 2019 when howard stern decided to
probe him about it i didn't think peter
jackson actually wanted me on the film
because i think he was forced into
talking to me because there was a moment
of time when everybody wanted me and
everything crow knew that something
wasn't right when he spoke to jackson
over the phone about the part though he
said he had an instinct jackson wanted
someone else for the part viggo
mortensen
kate winslet started getting linked with
a possible appearance in the lord of the
rings as soon as newline announced that
peter jackson was going to spearhead its
ambitious three-movie project the
director gave the british starlet her
big break when he cast her in 1994's
heavenly creatures a psychological drama
based on a famous new zealand case
involving two teenage killers
by the time jackson started casting for
the lord of the rings winslet was a huge
star having been nominated for academy
awards in the best supporting actress
and best leading actress categories for
1995's sense and sensibility and 1997's
titanic respectively
she had her pick of projects at the time
and the lord of the rings just wasn't
appealing enough
winslet was reportedly offered the role
of rohan shieldmaiden eowyn but she had
some commitment issues according to an
email allegedly written by former new
line cinema president of production
michael deluca the supposed email which
was forwarded to the lord of the rings
fan site for one ring by an inside
source read winslet's unavailable i'm
afraid i think she passed on the project
due to the length of time it takes
some people might view that as a gross
error of judgment on winslet's part but
her career didn't suffer as a result
she's been nominated for another four
oscars in the years since
winning one
uma thurman certainly has a high fantasy
look about her it's easy to imagine the
actress as galadriel but that's not the
part that peter jackson had in mind for
her the director wanted thurman to play
eowyn the same character that kate
winslet was approached about
thurman also turned the part down though
unlike winslet it wasn't just a time
issue
she and her then-husband ethan hawk had
just welcomed their first daughter maya
when the offer was made presenting the
new mother with a difficult choice in
the end thurman decided to put family
first and reject jackson's overtures
though she later admitted that the
decision still haunts her she confirmed
to mtv in 2008
yeah i was asked it just caught me at
the wrong moment i wish i had done it oh
i truly wish i could have been able to
take that plunge and maybe i should have
but i just couldn't at the time when she
appeared on the late show with stephen
colbert almost a decade later the kill
bill star admitted that rejecting the
lord of the rings was quote one of the
worst decisions of her entire career i
just had my first child
and i just i don't know i was a little
housebound
at one stage husband and wife team uma
thurman and ethan hawke looked set to
appear in the lord of the rings together
with the letter confirming his planned
involvement at the toronto film festival
hawke not only revealed that he would be
playing boromir's younger brother
faramir a role that eventually went to
australian actor david wenham he also
let slip that tolkien's enigmatic
supporting character tom bombadil had
been cut from the screenplay
the actor went on to gush over the
author's work claiming he had been a fan
of the tolkien series since childhood
despite his obvious excitement hawke
pulled out of the picture
perhaps leaving his wife at home to care
for their newborn daughter after she had
turned down a part in the same movie
wasn't an option for the actor who takes
parenthood so seriously that he was
inspired to write a book about it
his now ex-wife has admitted that she
regrets rejecting the lord of the rings
but does hawke feel the same
he didn't explicitly say that he wished
he had taken the pharamia role but when
he sat down with variety in 2018 he
revealed that he was still waiting for
his big blockbuster moment saying
before i die i would really like to give
a meaningful performance inside a really
commercial film
lucy lawless is best known for starring
in the much-loved xena warrior princess
the new zealander seemed to be the
perfect fit she had plenty of fantasy
experience and the kind of flawless
features that galadriel is known for in
the novels but it wasn't meant to be
sometimes people do things that they
regret lawless was pregnant when jackson
approached her about the role and the
director clearly failed to sell the lord
of the rings to her because she forgot
to turn up for the audition
in a 2003 interview with hot celebs
magazine lawless revealed that she also
turned down a chance to appear in fox's
franchise opener x-men at the time
despite knowing that she probably
wouldn't get another shot at the big
leagues
she said
you know what might happen by the time
i'm ready and want to do a multi-year
contract they won't want me but what can
i do i've turned down great things it's
not worth it if your children are
miserable
her prediction came true and although
lawless is still working today having
starred in the australian crime series
my life is murder in 2019 and voiced an
alien queen in two 2020 episodes of star
wars resistance her career could have
been a whole lot different if she had
agreed to portray tolkien's telepathic
elf
what's stronger a witch king or a white
wizard and what happened to all those
magic rings anyway keep watching to find
out everything you didn't know you
wanted to know about the mythology of
lord of the rings
right from the get-go elves and dwarves
clearly have some serious beef indeed
these two ancient middle-earth races are
at odds at practically every step in the
hobbit the dwarves are less than
friendly with the elves of rivendell and
they're later straight up imprisoned by
the elves of mirkwood in the lord of the
rings gimli and legolas begin their
friendship at odds the elven princeling
hates the idea of going into moria and
the dwarf is nearly refused admission
into lothlorien ishkakui
i go
that was not so courteous the animosity
between elf and dwarf is a theme that
stretches far back through their ancient
histories which are told in the
silmarillion this book reveals that the
root of the conflict can be found in
each race's creation middle earth's
dwarves were brought into being by an
angelic creature named alay who made
them in an act of disobedience as he
waited for the creator il uvatar to
bring the elves into the world allez
became impatient so he made the dwarves
instead eluvitar caught owlette
red-handed but the creator chose to give
these new creations their own individual
wills however he also told aolay that
often strife shall arise between thine
and mine the children of my adoption and
the children of my choice this
immediately set the tone for the dwarves
to live fiercely independent lives
separate from the other children of
iluvatar and often in direct competition
with them
[Music]
in the two towers tree beard tells mary
and pippin that orcs were made in
mockery of elves during middle earth's
great darkness however tolkien never
totally clarified the exact origin of
the orcs nevertheless in the
silmarillion he does offer one very
compelling account for their creation
tolkien explains that when the elves
first came into existence they were
alone in middle earth living in
childlike innocence in a world of
perpetual starlight eventually they
became afraid of wandering off alone as
an unknown being they called the hunter
had begun to carry them off this hunter
turned out to be the dark lord morgoth
and his servants the fate of his
captives was uncertain but it was
surmised by the wise of middle earth
that by slow arts of cruelty the elves
were corrupted and enslaved and thus did
morgoth breathe the hideous race of the
orcs in envy and mockery of the elves of
whom they were afterwards the bitterest
foes while the orcs likely began as
corrupted elves before long they had
taken on their own attributes but even
as the enemies of middle earth's free
peoples tolkien points out that deep in
their dark hearts the orcs still loathe
the maker of their misery the creation
of the orcs has been referred to by
tolkien as morgoth's vilest deed and the
one that caused the most defense to
iluvatar
so you know where orcs come from but
what's the deal with urukai how are
saruman's oversized servants different
from their orcish counterparts after all
they appear to have orcish features but
they're uncommonly tall and muscular
much like the history of the orcs
themselves tolkien was never crystal
clear about the answer to this question
but he does offer a few hints in the two
towers
whom do you serve
first of all it seems fair to suggest
that the urakai are an offshoot breed of
orcs in other words they are at least
partially part of the orc family tree in
the two towers treebeard states that
saruman has been doing something to the
orcs something dangerous for these
eisengarders are more like wicked men he
adds that normal orcs cannot stand the
sun but the urukai can even if they
don't exactly love it from there
treebeard wonders are they men he has
ruined or has he blended the races of
orcs and men during the battle of helm's
deep the urukai are also referred to as
half-orcs and goblin men while the truth
remains hazy it appears that the white
wizard may have crossbred orcs and men
to create his own breed of soldier
the exact purpose of the one ring is
kept vague in both the lord of the rings
films and the books however if you
cobble together enough of the facts it
is possible to paint a better picture of
the true power of everyone's favorite
trinket in the silmarillion sauron
forges the one ring part way through the
second age when this happens he binds
the other rings of power to it in order
to gain an intimate level of domination
over their owners in essence sauron is
able to use the ring to see what the
other ring bearers are thinking and even
control their thoughts
however sauron's initial plan backfires
and the elves proved strong enough to
resist his will nevertheless the one
ring retains its control over most of
the other rings of power existing
primarily as an instrument of evil
domination while this is the primary
purpose of the one ring it also provides
the wearer with several other advantages
obviously it can make an individual
disappear when they want to it can also
slow the aging process or even halt it
indefinitely on top of that when sam
briefly puts on the ring after fleeing
shelob's lair he is able to understand
the conversation of nearby orcs in the
text tolkien suggests that the ring may
have given him the ability to translate
the orcs language notably the same thing
happened to bilbo when he encountered
the spiders of mirkwood in the hobbit
the timelines of peter jackson's movies
and tolkien's books come to cross
purposes fairly early in the telling
arguably this throws off the timing of
the whole story leading to the question
how long does frodo have the one ring
before he becomes mordor bound the
correct answer in the books is 17 years
frodo receives his inheritance from
bilbo on his 33rd birthday in the movie
version of that long expected party mary
and pippen are practically full grown
when they get into trouble with gandalf
this gives the understandable impression
that very little time passes between
that event and the moment at which the
four hobbits begin their quest the truth
is though in the book version of the
fellowship of the ring a whopping 17
years elapsed between frodo getting the
ring and frodo leaving the shire and
that's 17 years exactly in fact he
receives the ring on his 33rd birthday
and departs the shire on his 50th in the
novel this goes a long way in explaining
why he's so attached to the ring right
from the get-go while john noble does a
fantastic job portraying denathore on
the silver screen the cinematic version
of the steward of gondor doesn't exactly
do justice to the book he's arrogant to
a fault blinded by pride and literally
tells his men to leave minas tirith when
it comes under attack
[Music]
worst of all he orders faramir to attack
oscar when there's no question that he's
going to be moaned down by an army of
orcish archers all of this behavior is
so over the top that it begs the
question what the heck is going on well
if you turn to the original text the
answer becomes clear namely the fact
that his poor judgment is far more
nuanced in the books denathore isn't a
mad tyrant openly trying to kill his son
on the contrary while he does make his
disappointment in vermeer clear he
doesn't send his son on a suicide
mission instead when faramir retreats to
ministerith to report on the situation
in auscalia denathore simply asks him to
return and bolster the defenses more
generally the steward's hopeless despair
comes about because he has been battling
sauron's will through one of the
palantir all in all the book version of
denathor is a deeply flawed man but he's
also strong and noble and gives
everything he has to the defense of
gondor
hobbits are a curious people they share
similarities with men dwarves and even
elves at times which often leads to the
question of whether or not tolkien meant
for them to be related to any of these
other races well they are related to one
of them men to be precise at least
they're most likely related to them
again tolkien left this one a little
open-ended in the prologue to the
fellowship of the ring he spends a
decent amount of time breaking down the
history ancestry and culture of the
little people in the middle of the
breakdown he straight up states that it
is plain indeed that in spite of later
estrangement hobbits are relatives of
men while this is presented as an
obvious fact he also points out that the
beginning of hobbits lies far back in
the elder days that are now lost and
forgotten he also points out that the
true relationship between hobbits and
men quote can no longer be discovered so
while tolkien refuses to make any
specific connection between the two he
all but declares that hobbits are a
miniature version of the big people
a number of rings of power appear
throughout the lord of the rings and the
hobbit movies nine rings are wielded by
mortal men doomed to die the three elven
rings are used to keep all that is good
and holy intact and of course there's
the one ring itself which serves as the
focal point to the entire story but what
about the seven dwarven rings these are
shown briefly at the beginning of the
fellowship of the ring and they're
mentioned every time the ring poem is
recited but that's about it so what
happened to them well gandalf provides a
bit of clarity on the subject in the
fellowship of the ring when he hastily
brings frodo up to date on the long lore
of the rings of power he briefly
mentions that seven the dwarf kings
possessed but three sauron has recovered
and the others the dragons have consumed
this is partially confirmed later on
when gandalf suggests that dragon fire
could destroy the lesser rings then at
the council of elrond gloyne informs the
group that a messenger from mordor asked
for the dwarf's help in hunting for the
one ring the price offered in exchange
three rings that the dwarf sires
possessed of old
one of the biggest issues that many fans
have with the lord of the rings movies
comes from a scene in the extended
edition of the return of the king in
which the witch king confronts gandalf
on the walls of minas tirith
faced with the awesome power of the
white wizard sauron's captain
nonetheless overpowers him destroying
his staff and sending him hurdling to
the ground so is gandalf the white
really weaker than one of the nazgul
while this is a generally speculative
question it's probably safe to assume
that peter jackson and company
overstepped a little here that's not a
knock against the witch king of course
angmar's erstwhile ruler is thousands of
years old wields a ring of power and is
backed by the strongest being in
middle-earth but we're not comparing him
to a run-of-the-mill mortal here or even
an elven lord this is gandalf he's an
angelic being placed inside a mortal
body one who is older than time itself
and happens to be secretly wielding one
of the elven rings of power no matter
which way you slice it the witch king
would never be able to defeat gandalf
this easily in the books the two
characters do briefly face each other
but before they can come to blows the
rohirrim arrive and the witch king
retreats still it's probably safe to say
that the witch king wouldn't have won
that fight
happened during tolkien's second age of
middle-earth that has led the creative
minds at amazon to explore this era
during their lord of the rings series
let's dive into this little disgust saga
a second age implies that there was a
first age that came before it and
tolkien's first age is the primary
subject of his book the silmarillion
the book focuses on the adventures and
tragedies of the elves in their epic
wars with the dark lord morgoth after
centuries of bloodshed morgoth is
finally defeated in the earth-shattering
war of wrath
the event is action-packed with tons of
dragons eagles orcs elves men and even a
bunch of balrogs other supernatural
creatures to boot when all is said and
done the survivors on both sides flee
most of the elves head west to the same
heavenly land that frodo and bilbo
sailed toward at the end of the return
of the king
however a few of the elves along with
the men dwarves and any surviving
baddies head further into middle earth
which is where the second age picks up
while amazon won't be exploring the
first age there's no doubt that it will
be an important backdrop as the show
unfolds
the second age begins with a bunch of
refugees looking for new homes and while
there are too many stories of settling
here in kingdom building there to
explain them all in detail
a few of these new settlements are worth
noting
first is meathland a port settled by
elves in the first year of the second
age
the harbor is located on the
northwestern shores of the continent and
it becomes middle-earth's primary
connection to the forgotten west fans of
the films will recognize meathland by
its more commonly known title of the
grey havens the same spot where frodo
and bilbo eventually head out to sea in
ring bearing retirement
i think i'm
quite ready for another adventure
almost 1700 years after the gray havens
is built the elvis stronghold rivendell
is founded by everyone's favorite
counselor elrond
this time the settling takes place by
necessity after elrond has a nasty
run-in with sauron also known as
imladris and the last homely house east
of the sea rivendell will stand as one
of the chief bastions of protection for
the free people of middle earth
throughout the rest of the second and
third ages
and it will go on to feature prominently
in the lord of the rings and hobbit
stories
one of the first casting leaks for
amazon series was morphed clark who was
slated to play a younger version of the
elven lady galadriel this brings up the
intriguing question of what galadriel
was up to several thousand years before
she shows frodo her mirror and spazzes
out when he offers her the one ring
[Music]
she may look young but galadriel is one
of the oldest beings in all of middle
earth
by the time of the second age she's
already thousands of years old and
married to her husband keleborn
the lord and lady bounce around living
with various elvish communities
throughout the entire second age
while the specifics of their story can
get a bit confusing eventually they
cross the misty mountains and relocate
to lothlorien but not as its rulers
the elvish power couple continues to
have a heavy influence on the affairs of
the age and galadriel is eventually
given her own elven ring which she uses
to keep her new home safe and prosperous
at some point she also gives birth to
their daughter calebrion who becomes the
wife of elrond and the mother of arwen
while galadriel in kelleborn's time to
truly shine won't come until the third
age there's no doubt they're some of the
primary movers and shakers of the second
age as well
so far we've talked a lot about elvish
events but the second age is actually
mostly focused on the affairs of men
while men have been around for quite a
while by this point there's one kingdom
in particular that really defines the
second age the island nation of numenor
after the destructive war of wrath the
valar the guardian spirits of middle
earth raise a giant star-shaped island
out of the ocean as a gift to the men
who fought against morgoth
the island and the nation that
eventually settles on it come to define
the second age the first men to settle
on the island are led by their king
elros the brother of elrond due to some
very convoluted family history the two
brothers and their children are given
the choice to live out their lives as
either immortal elves or mortal men
while elrond becomes an immortal elvish
lord elros becomes the first very mortal
king of numenor where he rules for a
little over 400 years
throughout the second age the island
nation remains a force to be reckoned
with and a central part of tolkien's
narrative
at the end of the first age the dark
lord morgoth is permanently banished
from middle earth however many of his
servants survive including the balrog
that fights gandalf in morya and sauron
the evil spirit that would eventually
become the lord of the rings was the
second in command under the dark lord
during the first age and after morgoth
is banished sauron himself
becomes the dark lord
stepping into the power vacuum left by
his master sauron becomes the main enemy
of the entire second and third ages
roughly a thousand years into the second
age he establishes mordor as his chief
base of operations and begins making
plans one does not simply walk into
mordor but we're not talking about
sauron the flaming eyeball here nor
about the towering dude in black armor
at this point in history sauron still
looks pretty good rather than attacking
his elvish enemies the dark lord
capitalizes on his still attractive
physical form calls himself anatar the
lord of gifts and begins pretending to
offer his friendship to any elves that
would listen to him this side of the
misty mountains
sauron as anatar spends the next few
centuries worming his way into the
affections of the elves of middle earth
while a few of the elvish lords like
elrond and galadriel don't trust him
most of the rest of the elves do
one group of elves the same one that
lives near the dwarves and kaza doom
becomes particularly enchanted by the
dark lord in disguise
they're led by a fellow named keller
brimbore and they're famous for being
incredible craftsmen
with anatar's help they begin to learn
how to forge rings of power
it's at this point that sauron secretly
forges the one ring
he pours a ton of his power into the
ring in order to use it to control the
other rings
when he puts the one ring on though the
elves instantly realize that they've
been duped and take their rings off in
order to avoid his domination
angry at the fact that his ring gave him
away before he was ready
sauron prepares to subdue the elves the
old-fashioned way with a war
once sauron's real intentions are
revealed he demands the other rings of
power claiming that the elves never
would have been able to make them
without his help which is technically
true with the exception of the three
elven rings
of course feeling betrayed the elves
refused to hand over any of their
powerful jewelry
with his pretext for war in hand sauron
attacks the free people of middle earth
in a bloody war that lasts for several
years and nearly leads to the villain's
total domination of the bulk of the
continent initially kelebrimbor and his
people are destroyed the dwarves retreat
to moria and elrond flees north to found
rivendell the dark lord also captures
the seven rings that eventually would go
to the dwarves and the nine rings that
would eventually be given to the black
riders
critically the three elven rings remain
hidden
just as sauron is preparing to do a
victory lap through middle-earth
the new minorians suddenly arrive
sending the dark lord's scampering back
to mordor with little more than a
bodyguard
this saves the elves men and dwarves
from total destruction
over the next several centuries the new
minorians and sauron continue to build
up their strength and jockey for power
and middle-earth
sauron spends the next millennia
rebuilding his strength he completes his
tower of bahra doer the one where he
resides later as a flaming eye
distributes the rings of power and sets
up the black riders as his terrifying
new servants he continues to dominate
practically everything in sight with the
crucial exception of the elven kingdoms
he failed to conquer and a few strong
but scattered settlements of the new
minorians along the coast of
middle-earth
eventually sauron declares that he is
the king of men a move that is insulting
to the very manly certainly unconquered
numenoreans
the new minorian king ar farzon the
golden invades middle earth with such a
resplendent army that sauron's minions
abandoned him without a fight
at this point sauron who still looks
like the attractive anatar willingly
surrenders to the new minorians and
becomes their hostage
this may come across as a cowardly move
on the surface but it ultimately spells
doom for the new menorians they bring
the dark lord back to their island
nation and it doesn't take long before
the prisoner begins working his
bewitchments on the king himself
once in a position of power
sauron begins convincing the king's
subjects to worship morgoth complete
with human sacrifices
sauron ultimately convinces the king of
numenor to attack the valar in their
land far to the west in a delusional
attempt to gain immortality this is
clearly an issue and it becomes one of
the rare cases in middle-earth history
when the supreme god eru iluvatar
himself
comes down to intervene
eru destroys the rebellious king's
armada of ships and sinks the insurgent
island in an atlantis-like catastrophe
interestingly it's at this point in
tolkien's mythology that the earth is
literally reshaped from a flat plain to
a round sphere
sauron himself is caught in the chaos
and while his spirit survives and heads
back to middle earth
his body is destroyed
the second age narrative tends to
revolve mostly around elves men and
their ongoing wars with sauron however
it's also one of the most prosperous
eras in all of dwarven history the
primary dwarven city and middle earth at
this time is kaza doom
at this point though there isn't a
balrog haunting the mines yet and the
subterranean city is alive with dwarven
life and activity
in addition the city becomes even more
rich and famous after many talented
dwarves from the eastern dwarven
mansions flee west at the end of the
first age during the second age the
dwarves strike up a particularly
friendly relationship with a neighboring
group of elves that live right next to
their western gates
speak trend
and enter
these are the same elves that end up
making the great rings of power that the
one ring is designed to control in the
two highly skilled races get along
swimmingly for a long time
eventually when this kingdom of elves is
attacked by sauron the dwarves will try
to help their friends
unfortunately
they come too little and too late and
end up retreating and locking themselves
up in kaza doom where they stay out of
most of the rest of the major events of
the age
the last two and a half centuries of the
second age focus on the founding of two
important kingdoms one of which any lord
of the rings fans should recognize
we're talking about arnor and gondor the
two kingdoms founded by a group of
faithful numenoreans who rejected
sauron's silver-tongued lies and
survived the destruction of their home
by sailing away before the catastrophic
chaos erupted
when they arrive in middle-earth they
join forces with the elves and settle
down to a new life
these are the same people that build
among many other things saruman's tower
of orthanc the city of minas tirith and
the tower at weathertop
they also bring with them the white tree
that can be seen in the return of the
king as well as the palantiri the shiny
seeing stones that saruman uses to chat
with sauron everything looks hunky-dory
for the two new kingdoms until sauron
shows up in middle-earth again
when they realize that sauron has
returned to mordor the exiled
numenoreans named the fiery mountain in
his land mount doom
yes that mount doom not long after this
sauron begins attacking his enemies yet
again and the elves men dwarves and all
other free peoples in middle earth
joined together to form the last
alliance the initial sequence in the
fellowship of the ring centers on this
last alliance showing the war in which
sauron is destroyed the ring is cut from
his finger and essildor tragically
refuses to destroy it in the fires of
mount doom destroy it
no
you see dude
these moments at the beginning of the
monumental jackson trilogy mark the end
of the second age
not only does the era dovetail neatly
with the existing cinematic source
material
but it leaves a massive helping of epic
stories for the folks at amazon to dig
into
everything you ever knew about the lord
of the rings is a lie why did peter
jackson change so much from the books
keep watching to find out
perhaps the biggest misconception
regarding the world of middle earth is
that hobbits are as a race pretty weak
sure bilbo and frodo are heroic but most
fans think of them as exceptions from
the norm however the truth is that
hobbits can be quite sturdy and quite
fierce this is most evident in a key
part of the return of the king that is
actually emitted from the cinematic
adaptation where a de-powered saruman
leads a group of human ruffians to take
over the shire when frodo sam mary and
pippin return home they lead a revolt
and drive off the humans in fact when
nearly 100 humans come to try to reclaim
the shire 70 of them are killed in
combat with the hobbits many of them cut
down by axes why then did peter jackson
omit this from his hit movie other than
a brief glimpse in a vision during the
fellowship of the ring it's possible
that the universe would collapse under
the weight of yet another ending being
added to that movie so the hobbits get a
more traditional happy ending
one of the misconceptions about the lord
of the rings is that samwise gamgee is
little more than a source of comedic
relief and funny memes potatoes
boil em mash em stick em in a stew
however the most badass samwise gamgee
moment is one that is very easy to miss
when sam thinks that frodo has been
killed by sheila the giant spider sam
takes the ring to continue the quest
alone if that wasn't badass enough once
he saves frodo he just gives the ring
back why is this a big deal there are
almost no other instances of the ring
being freely given away remember it's a
huge deal when bilbo does it at the
start of the trilogy and at the end of
the tale gollum inadvertently saves the
day when he nibbles it off of frodo
because as it turns out frodo himself is
unable to willingly give it up
a common criticism of lord of the rings
is the fact that gandalf didn't just
summon some of those giant birds to
carry the fellowship to mordor the truth
is that using the great eagles in that
way was never an option first there's no
reason to think sauron wouldn't be ready
for an enemy to approach mordor from the
air remember all those nazgul on their
big dragons until sauron was defeated
the eagles couldn't easily get into
mordor second it's a flawed assumption
that gandalf could summon the great
eagles at will gandalf did not summon
the great eagles they came of their own
accord tolkien often portrays animals in
his stories as being blessed with as
much intelligence as humans as early as
the great eagle's first appearance in
the hobbit writer j.r.r tolkien made it
clear that the great eagles did not like
most two-legged things and would rarely
get involved with them they respected
gambolf and would occasionally help him
but they were never at his command even
to save middle-earth from sauron
another misconception about lord of the
rings that can be blamed entirely on the
movies is that losing the ring leads to
instant aging
[Music]
this is dramatized by the extreme
contrast of bilbo's relative youth at
the beginning of the first movie when he
is celebrating turning 111 years old and
his extremely elderly appearance when
they encounter him in rivendell now the
movies are deliberately cagey about the
timeline but the books tell us that 17
years pass between that birthday
celebration and frodo's quest and then
more years pass after the quest before
bilbo's ship leaves in that time bilbo
has seemingly aged quite a few decades
leading some fans to conclude that
losing the ring caused him to age
however this is canonically the opposite
of the truth and we know this because of
gollum gollum was pushing 600 years old
by the time he died and he had been
without the ring for over 60 years by
the time that happened if losing the
ring leads to the body's age catching up
gollum should have been dust well before
the fellowship of the ring even began
among die hard lord of the rings fans
there are four words almost guaranteed
to instigate a blind rage elves at
helm's deep this of course was a major
part of the climax of the two towers
movie with a small company of elves
arriving to help the beleaguered humans
drive off an entire host of invading
orcs and because these are adaptations
of a beloved series of books many people
figured this to was in the books but not
only was this event not in the books it
was canonically impossible in the books
peter jackson made the bold decision to
start his film adaptations by showing
audiences a pivotal moment in the
history of middle earth humans and elves
standing together to defeat sauron this
was notable not just because they
defeated sauron but because this was the
last alliance between the two races they
went back to each doing their own thing
and by the time the main events of the
modern plot unfold the elves are fading
in prominence from middle earth remember
it's actually a major plot point that
big important elrond has assembled a
team of humans hobbits a dwarf and a
wizard the elves are supposed to be
leaving this world behind and letting
the immortal races deal with their own
problems so having elves show up at
helm's deep violates a major theme of
the entire series
while books are perfect places for
illusions and metaphors it is the job of
the movie to visually spell everything
out peter jackson took his role very
seriously when it came to return of the
king leading to one of our primary
misconceptions that sauron is a giant
eyeball when audiences first see sauron
he is a towering warrior in the
flashback battle sequence at the
beginning of fellowship of the ring when
they next see him though he is seemingly
a giant eye one that aragorn resolves to
distract with a flashy battle sequence
while sam and frodo finished their task
this giant eyeball is a creation made
especially for the movies and it makes
many people think that the eye is
literally sauron however tolkien's own
letters clarify that sauron had a
physical body by the time the ring was
physically destroyed something hinted at
in the hobbit prequel films
thanks to vigo mortensen and the face
that launched a thousand fanfics it's
easy to take aragorn's age for granted
after all mortensen was 43 years old
when fellowship of the ring came out and
it seemed a reasonable age for a
seasoned warrior who can still kick
orcish ass however the character of
aragorn is supposed to be twice that age
at the time of their adventures there's
even a deleted scene where eowyn is
highly confused when aragorn tells her
that he fought in battle alongside her
grandfather then you must be at least
60.
seventy
you cannot be eighty
so what's up with this exceptionally old
age aragorn was not like mortal men as
he was the sildore's heir was the last
of the numenoreans a group of humans
with exceptionally long life whose
homeland was destroyed in an
atlantis-style cataclysm long ago
this is part of the tragic history the
character often bears with him and is
part of his concern that he may repeat
some of the same errors that his
ancestors did
one of the most powerful moments from
return of the king is when eowyn the
shield maiden defeats the witch king the
witch king feels quite confident because
of a prophecy that no man can kill him
at which point aon disguised as a male
warrior reveals that she is a woman and
stabs him in the face
i am no man
but mary deserves just as much credit
before aoen gets her awesome killing
stroke in audiences see mary stab the
witch king with his blade the movies
gloss over the importance of these
blades with aragorn simply handing them
out at weathertop the books however made
clear that mary's blade was forged with
magical enchantments specifically made
to hurt the witch king thus mary happens
to stab the witch king with one of the
only weapons that can hurt him opening
the door for eowyn to complete the
prophecy
gandalf is a wizard yes but he's
actually not the kind of wizard we're
used to gandalf isn't a wizard in the
same way that say harry potter is a
wizard he's not someone who showed
aptitude for magic as a child and so was
sent to some wizard school and given a
big tome and taught a bunch of spells no
gandalf was created as a wizard and sent
to middle-earth to protect it the valar
were essentially the gods of middle
earth and they sent gandalf there along
with saruman radagast and two other
wizards these five wizards acted as
agents of the gods they were made to
look human and given magical and
physical abilities beyond normal men
they existed for millennia even longer
than the elves this is why gandalf knows
so much it's why no matter where the
fellowship goes he's already been there
and always seems to know someone he's
been alive long enough to travel to
every corner of middle earth and back
again hundreds of times over and it's
why after he dies during his battle with
the balrog gandalf returns to life
because the gods resurrected him to
complete his mission to redeem the world
from the devil called sauron
denethor was portrayed as a vengeful and
cowardly madman in peter jackson's
return of the king john noble played
denethor to perfection but there was a
lot of information missing from the
movie that would have added more depth
to the character in the novel tolkien
makes it clear that denethor was
actually driven mad by an outside
magical influence by a palantir this is
the same sort of magic orb that also
corrupted saruman and almost possessed
pippin as it opens the user to sauron's
influence while denathor ultimately
failed as steward his fall is tragic he
was the leader of a besieged kingdom
searching for a way to stop an
unbeatable enemy he failed and the
consequence was madness but he went mad
trying to save his people and that's got
to count for something
peter jackson's adaptation of return of
the king may give you the impression
that gondor was the only place where
sauron's armies laid siege but that was
far from true this is alluded to briefly
in the extended version of return of the
king when legolas tells gimli he
believes the dwarves are busy with their
own battles but we don't hear any
specifics the appendices of lord of the
rings make it clear that at the same
time sauron's armies were smashing into
the walls of minas tirith the elves
dwarves and other humans of greater
middle earth were dealing with their own
invasions
sauron's armies in dulgadur the
abandoned city where gandalf sauruman
and galadriel encounter sauron in the
hobbit movies attacked lorien three
times once sauron was finally defeated
galadriel traveled to the city and
destroyed it the wood elves were also
waging war against the orcs in their own
forests and eventually they managed to
expel them the humans of dale the city
at the foot of the lonely mountain in
the hobbit weren't as successful as the
elves though they were aided by the
dwarves sauron's armies attacked dale
and overwhelmed its defenders humans and
dwarves alike took shelter in the lonely
mountain and the orcs laid siege to its
gates once the one ring was destroyed
the combined armies of humans and
dwarves were able to route the orcs but
not before both the human and dwarven
kings were killed
though he ultimately betrays frodo and
the fellowship after being corrupted by
the one ring's power tolkien makes it
clear in his novel that boromir is
actually a noble warrior he's one of the
most skilled swordsmen in the fellowship
and possibly the strongest in battle
scenes he performs better than most with
the possible exception of aragorn he's
flawed but he's not the mess of nerves
peter jackson depicted in fellowship of
the rings except for his last stand
boromir is hardly seen in jackson's
fellowship battle scenes but the
extended edition of the film revealed a
number of cutscenes and lines that
showed him in a better light in a
lothlorian scene for example when the
rest of the fellowship is silent boromir
is the only one to reach out and tell
frodo not to blame himself for gandalf's
presumed death
gandalf's death was not in vain
nor would he have you give up hope
like his father boromir wasn't a bad guy
at all he was just a desperate man who
lost hope while trying to save his
people
many fans were quite annoyed by the film
portrayal of pharamir this is because it
led to this kind of widespread
assumption that pharamir is like boromir
light that is he's just another corrupt
and greedy human who is eager for glory
and power and he only changes his mind
at the 11th hour however the fair mere
of the books is the polar opposite of
boromir through a combination of
intelligent interrogation and sam's
inability to keep his mouth shut he
finds out that they are carrying a
powerful weapon against sauron one that
boromir greatly desired for humanity to
have and when the pharamir of the books
finds this out he merely reiterates his
promise to help the hobbits out because
he had made a vow unlike peter jackson's
version who initially decides to turn
them over to dad to score some points
not cool
at some point it just became an
unquestioned truth that hobbit feet
along with being hairy and necessarily
resilient are disproportionately large
like if you took a clown and magically
turned his floppy clown shoes into
exceptionally hairy feet that's what
hobbit feet look like in the films the
truth is that tolkien never wrote
anything about hobbit feet being
particularly large in fellowship of the
ring he wrote that hobbit feet had quote
tough leathery soles and that they were
quote clad in a thick curling hair much
like the hair of their heads but he made
no mention about their feet being
particularly large sean astin who played
samwise gamgee in peter jackson's
adaptations would likely have preferred
a more faithful interpretation in the a
day in the life of a hobbit special
feature on the extended edition of
fellowship of the ring director peter
jackson revealed that aston annoyed at
the time it took to apply the hobbit
foot prosthetics kept jackson up to date
on his personal tally of how many days
the prosthetics were applied versus how
many days the feet appeared in shots we
have to be really honest and say that
when the days that we don't have feet
we're really excited
partly due to the enduring popularity of
the lord of the rings elves remain a
staple of high fantasy and their
physical appearance tends to follow
specific rules they're all stunningly
beautiful creatures with men and women
sporting equally long and often blonde
hair and they have pointy ears but
tolkien never wrote that blonde hair was
a dominant feature of his elves in fact
many of them such as elrond and arwen
have black hair though legolas is almost
always portrayed as having blonde hair
tolkien never actually describes his
hair color legolas father thranduil
however is one of the few elves to
explicitly be described as blonde
tolkien also never wrote anything to the
effect of elf men having the same
straight long hair as women so that a
bunch of elf men and women together look
like a line of actors waiting for a
shampoo commercial audition in fact
believe it or not tolkien never even
wrote in any of his books that elf ears
were pointy maybe he never meant for
them to be thought of as pointy or maybe
he thought elves were common enough in
legend and myth that the detail wasn't
needed regardless unless someone shows
tolkien's elves baking cookies and trees
for keebler or making toys for santa we
can probably all agree they've gotten a
pretty good deal in pop culture so far
and don't have a lot to complain about
in the many decades since it was first
published the lord of the rings has
remained one of the world's most popular
novel series and peter jackson's iconic
movie trilogy has only made the story
endure that much longer being so popular
of course you're bound to get a few
crazy fan theories thrown into the mix
here are a few of the lord of the rings
series that if true would turn the whole
of middle earth on its head
even casual tolkien fans will have heard
of one of the story's most notorious
criticisms to keep it short why didn't
the fellowship just use the eagles to
fly to mount doom and destroy the ring
on the surface it seems like a fair
question to ask and there are plenty of
perfectly reasonable answers to it too
the one fan theory in particular goes
beyond just explaining why the eagles
weren't up for the task it actually
suggests that using them as transport
was a plan all along this theory
suggests that after being saved by the
eagles from his imprisonment on top of
orthanc gandalf decides that this wing
transportation is surely the best way to
catch sauron by surprise and destroy the
ring the crux of this theory rests on
the suggestion that when gandalf de grey
engages in combat with the balrog his
now iconic final line should be taken
literally
[Music]
the idea is that he's just not telling
his companions to get out of moria he's
trying to communicate his plan to use
the eagles to reach mordor of course
this doesn't work and by the time he
returns as gandalf the white he's got a
whole new agenda to pursue of course
gandalf could also have just been
telling the fellowship to quit their
daughterling and get the heck out of
dodge just go with whatever works for
you
smeagol is one of the most pitiful
characters from the lord of the rings
and in a way one of the most lovable too
anyone with the heart should be able to
feel for the poor wretch as he struggles
with a centuries-long obsession with a
powerful force beyond his own
comprehension then of course there's
gollum the other side of his split
personality in the films gollum
basically represents all the bad stuff
he's hateful violent and willing to stop
at nothing to get hold of his precious
ring while most people generally accept
that these two characters make up a kind
of multiple personality disorder on
spiegel's part one fan theory suggests a
wholly different take rather than simply
writing off gollum a smeagol's evil side
this theory goes out on a lemon claims
that gollum is a legitimate personality
or its own that stems from within the
one ring itself this theory rests on the
fact that when bilbo has possession of
the ring he acts very similarly to
smeagle's golem personality towards the
end of the story frodo begins to act
this way too in short anyone tempted by
the ring and not just smeagol can
exhibit snippets to this identity and
upon giving into the ring's dominance
would themselves be completely consumed
by it it would have happened to bilbo it
almost happened to frodo and did it
probably happen to you too
during the opening chapters of the
fellowship of the ring it's revealed
that frodo's parents drowned in a
boating incident while this was
officially an accident darker rumors
suggested that his mother actually tried
to push his father into the water and he
pulled her in with him accident or not
that was the story as far as everyone
knew it until now according to one
reddit fan theory the given story of
this so-called accident is actually a
misdirect instead the theory proposes
that it was none other than gollum
himself who killed his future masters
parents as they coasted along the water
after dinner in the moonlight while the
poster admits to the coincidence would
have been a stretch they do make some
solid arguments for their theory for one
thing golem was searching around for his
lost ring at the time of frodo's parents
death still looking for bilbo baggins of
the shire frodo's father was named drogo
baggins so who's to say the villainous
creature didn't simply bump off the
first baggins he ran across unable to
find the ring on drogo's body golem
could have then had itself drawn towards
the one ring's master while it takes a
little stretching to fit with tolkien's
narrative this theory does throw up the
tantalizing prospect of a version of the
story in which frodo discovers that the
creature who benefited so frequently
from his mercy actually killed his own
parents
okay so this theory is kind of a twofer
let's start with the more clear-cut one
that tolkien included cannibalism in his
trilogy more specifically the idea that
grima worm wormtongue ate hobbit flesh
during the scouring of the shia chapter
and the return of the king saruman
reveals that his lackey worm tongue
killed frodo's corrupt relative lotho
during the scene the fallen wizard
states worm killed your chief stabbed
him in asleep i believe buried him i
hope though worm has been very hungry
lately and this is that last little
zinger that has led many to question if
worm sung actually straight up eight
lotho's body in an attempt to stave off
his extreme hunger if he did this kind
of mistreatment on sauron's part would
go a long way in explaining what pushed
worm tongue into finally snapping and
killing his master cannibalism aside
however another theory suggests that the
idea that soromon's mistreatment of worm
tongue wasn't just turning him into the
pale decrepit wretch that he became it
was actually transforming him into an
orc in other words after creating his
hybrid or akai earlier in the story it's
possible that sarah mum was
experimenting once more this time with
warping a man into an entirely new breed
of orc it's a chilling thought that
could have had drastic repercussions for
middle earth if worm tongue hadn't been
killed before the transition could fully
take place
here's another worm tongue theory though
this one is at least a little less
grotesque this theory has to do with the
rings of power but not the ones you'll
have encountered before instead it
tackles the idea that soroman might have
attempted to craft rings of his own
after all sariman emulated the dark lord
in most of the things that he did so why
not make rings of his own two there are
multiple instances in the trilogy where
it's suggested that soroman has an
interest in the other rings of power
when gandalf tells the story of his
captivity at the council of elrond for
instance he specifically points out that
he'd noticed that soroman was wearing a
ring on top of that when saruman
announces his treachery to gandalf he
refers to himself as saruman ringmaker
if you can assume from these hints that
sarah mann was busy making his own ring
then why would he stop at making one for
himself wouldn't he want to take after
sauron and create other rings to use as
a tool for the domination of others the
same way sauron took control of the
nazgul what's more this theory suggests
that none other than grima worm tongue
is in possession of one of saruman's
rings forcing him to serve his wizard
league master without question until the
very end
fans of the lord of the rings books will
be very familiar with tom bombadil this
enigma of a character is a mysterious
and unspeakably powerful being that
lives out in the old forest just beyond
the edge of the shire now tom has no
interest in the affairs of outsiders or
the war going on in middle earth well
that's what he says at least one theory
however suggests that tom bombadil is
none other than the witch king himself
okay don't laugh too hard before you
hear at least a few of the arguments in
favor of this theory for instance when
the hobbits run into the merry old
fellow in the fellowship of the rink tom
has a noticeable glint in his eye when
the black riders are mentioned and then
there's the fact that he can see frodo
clearly when the hobbit is wearing the
one ring just like the witch king at
weathertop and when tom puts a magical
piece of jewelry on his own finger it
has no effect on him much in the same
way that it wouldn't have any effect on
a true servant of sauron either of
course if by some crazy happenstance
this theory were to be true it would
mean frodo was saved and looked after by
the witch king for a considerable chunk
of time which all things considered
seems unlikely
early on in the two towers aragorn
legolas and gimli chase a troop of orcs
and urakai that have captured their
hobbit friends merry and pippin
eventually they discover their enemies
have been destroyed and the hobbits are
missing as they prepare to head into the
forest of feyngorn to search for them
they run into an interesting character
in the book at least as they said
resting by a fire in the dark they
suddenly spot an old bent man leaning on
a staff and wrapped in a great cloak
with his wide brimmed hat pulled down
over his eyes before the trio can react
the man disappears without a trace when
they meet gandalf shortly afterward he
clarifies that it wasn't him and so it
must have been saruman however one
theory suggests that it was none other
than radagast the brown the giveaway
there's little to no proof anywhere that
saruman ever wears a hat the brown
wizard on the other hand frequently does
radagast plays a significant part in the
hobbit trilogy and makes a brief
appearance in the book version of
fellowship of the ring but if this
theory is true it would indicate that
radagast was more active during the war
of the ring than anyone could have
guessed
it's strange to think of three heads is
particularly enticing but in the
fellowship of the ring that saw gimli
asked for when galadriel offers him a
parting gift on the surface this present
seems cute enough if a little odd but
gimli isn't the first person to want in
galadriel's golden tresses way back in
the first stage the elf lord theonor
requested a strand of hair from
galadriel three times it was often said
by the elves that the light of the last
two trees of valinor had endured in
galadriel's hair and this inspired
feyenoord to create the legendary jewels
known as the silmarils but theonor was
turned down repeatedly and never got his
hands on even a single strand of
galadriel's hair for her to then bestow
three hairs on gimli is a seriously big
deal especially since gimli is a dwarf
part of a race that doesn't exactly get
along well with the elves
all of this has inspired a theory that
the three hairs are actually the great
opening gesture in an act of diplomacy
peace and reconciliation between the two
races the fact that galadriel decides
he's more worthy of this gift than one
of the greatest elf lords who's ever
lived is one heck of a statement and if
gimli eventually managed to set the
three golden hairs in imperishable
crystal as he claimed it may have
ultimately precipitated the lasting
peace between elves and dwarves for all
his faults the hobbit trilogy could be
pretty fun it was exciting too some of
the time and you can't say it wasn't
colourful but let's be honest it was
also a bit of a train wreck
from all of its overstuffed storylines
lengthy battle scenes and ridiculous cgi
one brilliant theorist has suggested an
explanation that fixes the entire fiasco
with a clever twist it's all a tall tale
from bilbo's perspective see over the
course of his life bilbo developed
something of a love for storytelling
and he's not afraid of embellishing
these stories from time to time either
at the council of el runs when asked to
tell a story he has to start with the
caveat that is actually the true story
saying if someone's heard me tell it
otherwise i asked them to forget it and
forgive me in short bilbo loves to
exaggerate his stories and the hobbit
films are actually a depiction of
tolkien's classic novel from mr bagan's
own perspective talk about a useful
cop-out
immortal being daughter of elrod wife of
aragorn and queen of gondor
arwin the elf lived quite a long and
adventurous life even before frodo and
friends stumbled into her neck of the
woods in fellowship of the ring
here's arwen's entire backstory
explained
ancestry is often a key part of what
defines a person's path in life and with
arwin it's essential right from birth
her lineage both in the recent and
distant past makes her a prime candidate
for the middle earth limelight let's
start with the familiar faces first
arwen's dad is elrond as the leader of
rivendell a venerable warrior and a
famous counselor arwen's father is
practically always at the center of the
continent's politics and wars and his
daughter is often by his side in
rivendale observing the action
and then there's arwen's maternal
grandmother galadriel the lady of the
golden wood is about as old as an elf
can get and she's witnessed nearly all
of middle earth's long dramatic history
she has incredible power wields an elven
ring and is one of sauron's chief
enemies
while having elrond and galadriel as her
family members is already enough to set
our win up as a pretty important shielf
the hereditary connections don't stop
there arwin's family history is studded
with famous people particularly through
her father
elrond's father is aaron deal the
mariner the half-elf half-man hero that
saves the good guys from destruction at
the end of the first stage of
middle-earth history on top of that
elrond's mother is elwing the
granddaughter of the man baron and the
half-elven half-angelic luthien the
power couple and one of tolkien's most
famous first age epics and the thing is
we're only touching on the most famous
of our relatives here there are several
others who play critical roles in
tolkien's other writings especially the
silmarillion suffice it to say arwen is
the middle-earth equivalent of the
offspring of a marriage between a rock
star and a hollywood celebrity for those
of you who didn't notice she's also
descended from men elves and the angelic
maiar giving her and her immediate
family a unique connection to all three
races
according to the appendix of the return
of the king arwen is born 241 years into
the third age
that makes her approximately
2778 years old by the time the one ring
is destroyed which isn't terribly old
for an elf in comparison galadriel is
over 8 000. however it does give her a
good step up on her future husband's
88-year lifespan when arwen is born the
world is relatively peaceful a few
hundred years away from the epic war of
the last alliance that's the event
depicted in the opening sequence of the
fellowship of the ring where men elves
and dwarves join together to resist
sauron's first run at conquering the
continent when the dust settles the dark
lord is defeated the ring has been cut
from his hand and middle-earth settles
down for a long period of relative peace
and prosperity the primary thing to
point out during these early centuries
of armin's life is the fact that while
the power of men grows in middle-earth
the elves and dwarves slowly begin to
fade into obscurity and that's not to
say that they're inconsequential places
like lothlorien rivendel and khazad doom
are still powerful and influential
however they stop trending up at this
point in time and if anything begin to
lose the larger political and military
power that they once had her people may
have been slowly fading but the first
few thousand years of arwen's life are
ones of peaceful comfort she spends a
lot of her time bouncing between
rivendell and lothlorian with her
grandparents in the return of the king
she even casually mentions that she'd
been in lothlorian for a while
while there aren't a ton of details on
arwen's early activity the bulk of her
time for the greater part of 3000 years
seems to have been spent following this
pattern of living in one of the two
elven havens or traveling between them
in addition to her famous father and
grandmother artwin also has two older
twin brothers elladan and elro here as
well as a mother named calebrion however
over time she sees each of these
familial connections less often
primarily due to a tragic event that
happens to her mother about 500 years
before the war of the ring tragedy
strikes the family when their mother is
captured by orcs in the misty mountains
she's eventually found and rescued by
her sons but by then she's been tortured
and poisoned a devastated elrond manages
to save her life showing a glimpse of
the skill that he later uses to save
frodo from his deadly knife wound
however calebrian is so traumatized by
the experience that she never fully
recovers her former health and
eventually decides to leave middle-earth
to seek peace and healing in the blessed
realm the same place that frodo sails to
at the end of the return of the king
after this experience arwin's brothers
become especially bitter towards the
orcs and spend much of their time out
hunting their foes often teaming up with
the rangers in the process
eventually this morbid hobby even leads
to their being present when aragorn's
father is killed by orcs making his
young son chieftain in the process and
that serves as the perfect segue to
finally introduce arwen's beau
soon after one of arwen's trips back
from rivendale she decides to take a
walk and who should appear on the path
in front of her but a young man tell
everyone who the young man is legolas
this is no mere ranger
he is aragorn
at this point he's a 20 year old
stripling who's over the moon because he
just found out that he's the chieftain
of the dunadine and the heir to the
throne of gondor when the two meet it's
love at first sight at least for aragorn
arwen is little more than amused by his
head over heels attraction to her beauty
nevertheless aragorn sets his heart on
pursuing the elvish maiden which quickly
leads to a gentle but stern
confrontation with elrod the loremaster
sadly prophesies to the young ranger
that arwin will only marry him if he
becomes king and that in either case
either she or aragorn will eventually be
heartbroken by the situation
if sauron is defeated and aragorn made
king and all that you hope for comes
true
you will still have to taste the
bitterness of mortality
the budding relationship between arwen
and aragorn brings up an interesting
question
are the two related the short answer is
well yes
in fact in return of the king when we
learn how they met and aragorn explains
who he is arwen's immediate response is
that we are kin from afar
however while their bloodlines are
related it's definitely a very very
distant connection elrond's brother is a
man and we mean literally a man named
elros with their unique family history
the brothers and their descendants are
allowed to choose between either an
immortal or a mortal life
while elrond chooses immortality his
brother opts for mortality and ends up
leading a nation of men called numenor
over time that nation becomes one of
sauron's chief enemies and eventually
it's the numenoreans who set up the two
kingdoms of arnor and gondor when arnor
collapses its royal bloodline secretly
survives through the rangers and their
line of chieftains the last of whom is
aragorn
in other words there are dozens of
generations between arwyn and aragorn
making them technically but extremely
distantly related
considering the fact that tolkien came
from a world where english royalty was
constantly intermarrying with first and
second cousins the magnitude of the
distance in aragorn and irwin's
relationship would hardly have seemed to
be much of a concern
over time aragorn makes his case darwin
in a convincing yet indirect way when he
discovers that he doesn't have a shot
with elrond's daughter at present the
ranger leaves rivendell and heads out
into the wide world to forge his own
path
in the ensuing decades the exiled king
proves himself over and over again he
travels in the wild fights in disguise
in rohan and gondor befriends gandalf
and even makes a solo trip far into the
mysterious eastern and southern regions
of the continent over this time the son
of aerothorn evolves from an
inexperienced young man to a
battle-hardened warrior he gains wisdom
and experience beyond his years
[Music]
years that quickly add up
while still a drop in the bucket the
next time he meets arwen aragorn is
around 50 years old this time they hook
up in la florian and it's arwen who's
surprised to see aragorn walking towards
her through the trees they spend a
season together and darwin officially
falls in love with the now mature exiled
king
by the time they part ways they've
committed to marrying each other and
elrond gives his sad approval though he
clarifies that his daughter will marry
no one less than the king of arnor and
gondor
after she's officially betrothed to
aragorn arwen spends most of the next
few decades in rivendale as things ramp
up to the war of the ring
once the war breaks out her role varies
depending on if you're reading the books
or watching the movies
arwen remains more or less on the
sidelines throughout the book series
however just because she's out of sight
doesn't mean she's out of mind in fact
aragorn is depicted thinking of her on
multiple occasions
for instance when the fellowship arrives
in la florian frodo sees the ranger
wrapped in a memory in the same place
where he and arwen got engaged
in addition to remembrances arwen meets
with aragorn when he arrives with the
hobbits in rivendell she also personally
makes an enormous banner that aragorn
unveils during the battle of pelinor
fields using it to officially announce
his return as the king
arwen's role was dramatically beefed up
for peter jackson's trilogy
the shielf helps frodo escape from the
black riders revives a waterlogged
aragorn via a vision and is repeatedly
shown struggling with her father's
desire for her to leave middle earth
rather than become mortal
even in this enhanced role though
arwen's participation in the plot is
actually reduced from the original
cinematic scripts in an interview with
ign liv tyler herself clarified that the
character was supposed to be much more
heavily involved in the story in an
earlier version of the script she was
actually supposed to lead the elf
contingent that fights at helm's deep in
the two towers however as they shot the
movie the filmmakers realized that
inserting arwen into the violent action
wasn't doing justice to her character
tyler herself points out that you don't
have to put a sword in a woman's hand to
make her seem tough that's little actual
makeup of who arwin is and her sheer
will and strength and love for this man
was strong enough
whether she had been depicted in battle
or not though there's no doubt that
arwen is more present in the film
adaptations than she ever is in the
original the lord of the rings story
both the written and cinematic versions
of arwin's story reconnect when she
marries aragorn in all of the annals of
middle earth lore this becomes just the
third time that an elf and a man get
hitched with both of the previous unions
also taking place in their shared family
tree
their nuptials are a high water mark in
the story of the two lovers
of course arwen's marriage also means
she officially becomes the queen of the
reunited realms of gondor and arnor
practically overnight this makes her the
most powerful woman in all of middle
earth as queen she helps aragorn rule
their kingdom for 120 years
during that time she brings sam's
daughter eleanor to be her maid of honor
in minas tirith she also has at least
two daughters who remain nameless and a
son named eldarian who eventually
succeeds his father to the throne
one of the most complicated and
confusing elements about arwen's life is
her mortality or more accurately her
immortality that is replaced by
mortality
in essence arwen is allowed to choose
between being immortal or mortal since
she has both elves and men in her
ancestry
was my choice
however the specific ground rules for
this choice are never clarified by
tolkien
it would appear that at least once
someone chooses to be mortal the choice
isn't given to their children regardless
of the specifics arwen lives as an
immortal elf until she gives up her
immortality to marry aragorn i choose a
mortal life
this enables her to grant frodo her spot
on the ship headed west to the blessed
realm but it also sets her up for a
painfully difficult parting as well
when arwen discusses her choice to
become mortal in the return of the king
she explains that she is chosen quote
both the sweet and the bitter and 120
years after her marriage to aragorn the
bitter part really comes home to roost
after he passes and aldarian becomes
king it says in the book that in her
sorrow she says goodbye to her children
and her loved ones and then she leaves
minas tirith returning to her past home
of lothlorien however by this time
galadriel and her people have left and
no elves remain in the golden wood she
wanders there through the following
winter and then finally lies down to
rest in the same place where she had
betrothed herself to aragorn so many
years before there tasting the
bitterness at the very end of her mortal
life she passes away quietly eventually
surrounded by a green grave that will
never change until the world itself is
altered
we all know the story of the lord of the
rings and its many heroes villains and
epic battles the story of the one ring
itself however is a longer one with
history that stretches all the way back
to the beginning of j.r.r tolkien's
fictional universe
sauron the actual lord of the rings
referred to in the title of tolkien's
epic was created by the deity eru in the
time before the world was made in his
early life he was called myron and
served as a craftsman to hire beings
until he was corrupted by morgoth the
original dark lord of tolkien's world
morgoth attempted to conquer middle
earth in the first age and when he was
defeated mayron fled judgment hiding in
middle-earth building his power until he
could make his next move the elves
ultimately came to call him sauron as
the centuries passed sauron began
calling himself the lord of gifts and
visited the elves though some of the
elves including galadriel and elrond
distrusted him the elvin smith keller
brimbore was taken with sauron's gifts
and together they began forging the
rings of power they eventually gave 19
rings to the races of middle-earth
sauron forged the one ring in the
volcanic fires of mount doom pouring
much of his own essence and power into
it the plan was to use the one to
control the wearers of the other rings
unfortunately for sauron the
ring-bearing elves were able to sense
the presence of the dark lord and avoid
his control leading to a war against
sauron for the rings of power
the war finally ended when an army of
men joined with the elves sauron
retreated back to mordor to recover
more centuries passed as sauron
continued to fortify his stronghold in
mordor and completed the tower of
baradur
near the end of the second age he was
strong enough to again attempt conquest
of middle earth but the armies of
numenor the nation of men marched
against him
sauron surrendered and was taken as
prisoner but he was not humbled by his
supposed defeat in numenor sauron again
assumed a beautiful appearance and
convinced the numenoreans that they
should worship his old master morgoth it
was here that aru the supreme creator of
all intervened new menorah sank into the
sea its armies were drowned and sauron's
physical form was destroyed his spirit
however was able to return to mordor
tied to the material world by the one
ring
led by elendil the survivors of numenor
escape to middle earth sauron watched
the formation of their kingdoms and his
hatred of a lendil led him to attack
elendil and his sons including isildur
knew they couldn't battle sauron alone
and formed the last alliance with the
elves to make a stand against the
darkness the siege of bharadur lasted
for years until sauron finally came out
to join the fight himself
it was then that isildur took up his
father's sword narsil and cut the one
ring from sauron's hand
sauron was defeated and the victory
marked the end of the second age
sadly isildur was seduced by the one
ring's power and kept it for himself
only losing it when he was killed in an
ambush by orcs the ring vanished into a
river and would not be seen again for
centuries
for more than two thousand years the one
ring was lost that changed the day two
cousins smeagol and deagle went fishing
near the spot where a seal door was
killed there deagle discovered a gold
ring in the water smeagle was
immediately drawn in by the one ring's
power and when deagle refused to give it
to him smeagle responded by strangling
his cousin and taking the one ring for
himself
with the ring granting him an endless
life he spent 500 years alone in the
dark as his body and mind were twisted
by the ring over time he came to be
known as gollum
gollum and his ring lived in seclusion
for centuries until a hobbit named bilbo
baggins accidentally stumbled across the
creature's lair while lost in the misty
mountains
bilbo found the ring in the dark and
used it to escape gollum after a riddle
contest at which quite frankly bilbo
cheated
[Music]
in my pocket
that's not fair
though he initially lied about the ring
bilbo did eventually tell the wizard
gandalf the grey more details about how
he came to possess it
gandalf was able to deduce that it was
one of sauron's evil rings of power
still the wizard decided the ring was
relatively safe in the hobbit's hands
leaving bilbo to keep it at his home in
the shire
bilbo kept the ring for decades
intending to one day leave it to his
nephew frodo with gandalf's blessing
when the time came though bilbo seemed
reluctant to part with it this led
gandalf to realize that bilbo's ring was
not just one of the magic rings but the
ring sauron's long lost one ring the
danger of the one ring itself coupled
with gollum's recent emergence in middle
earth and the return of the dark forces
like the ring wraiths led gandalf back
to the shire to warn frodo he told the
young hobbit to set out for the elven
city of rivendell where elrond was
assembling a council
they decided that the ring must be taken
to mordor to be destroyed in the fires
of mount doom as it was the only way to
prevent sauron from eventually
reclaiming it frodo volunteered to be
the one to take it and was joined in his
quest by others
you have my sword
[Music]
the fellowship of the ring as frodo's
group was now known set out from
rivendell while agents of sauron
continue to pursue them and amass forces
leading to tragedy for the group
fly you fools
later when the fellowship was attacked
by orc warriors boromir a noble soldier
of gondor was killed while defending the
lives of the hobbits before he died
however boromir succumbed to temptation
and tried to take the ring from frodo
which led frodo to believe he needed to
leave in order to spare his allies the
burden of the ring's power sam refused
to let frodo go alone and so the two
ventured off to mordor together when
frodo and sam became lost trying to find
the way to mordor they realized that
gollum who had been set free after
torture at the hands of the orcs was
following them after capturing him frodo
and sam ordered him to lead them to
mordor a task he agreed to in order to
stay close to the ring
eventually frodo sam and gollum made
their way into sauron's dark realm
war erupted all around them as the
remainder of the fellowship continued to
battle orcish armies in a bid to buy
frodo time to destroy the ring gollum
meanwhile continued to plot against the
hobbits in order to retake the ring for
himself in his bid to eliminate the
hobbits gollum led them to what he
claimed was a shortcut to mount doom in
fact it was the lair of the giant spider
shelob who nearly killed the hobbit when
sam and frodo finally reached the fires
of doom frodo gave in to the ring's
power and put it on refusing to destroy
it it was here that gollum made his move
pouncing on frodo and biting off the
finger that held the ring gollum
reunited with his precious at last was
too lost in celebration to see where he
was standing he fell off the edge into
the magma below destroying himself and
the one ring sauron whose essence was
directly tied to the ring was defeated
and all of his armies instantly
collapsed
the lord of the rings is arguably the
most iconic fantasy series of all time
but what are the real stories behind
author j.r.r tolkien's beloved literary
classics and their cinematic adaptations
this is the untold truth of the lord of
the rings
well it began as you might expect
in a hole in the ground
there lived
a hobbit as tolkien explains in his
forward to the fellowship of the ring
the tale of the lord of the rings grew
in the telling with the author
discovering more of it as he went along
this was largely due to the fact that
the story had found its beginnings as a
sequel to tolkien's previously published
children's book the hobbit the thing is
the hobbit was initially supposed to be
a one-off thing in a letter to his
publisher to keane discussed how he was
struggling with the sequel to his
beloved work which had only been
connected to his other middleware
writings by virtue of an occasional name
drop or the odd character crossover
appearance such as elrond the son of
aarondale the mariner however the
success of the hobbit led to such demand
for more that eventually a sequel became
inevitable even as the new book slowly
took shape though it continued to be
seen as another hobbit book rather than
its own story for example tolkien's
close friend and literary sounding board
c s lewis was known to refer to the work
simply as the new hobbit once tolkien
settled on making bilbo's ring the
connecting point from one book to the
other however the new hobbit grew into a
massive story one that could easily
stand on its own it didn't take long
before the fellowship of the ring alone
dwarfed the hobbit in size it turns out
though that lengthening his story was
actually one of tolkien's main goals in
writing it the author points out in the
forward that the prime motive was the
desire of a tail teller to try his hand
at a really long story that would hold
the attention of the readers
tolkien also notes that while many
readers might find his work to be overly
long or boring his opinion is that the
most critical defect of the whole story
is the simple fact that it's too short
tolkien didn't always feel that way
about the lord of the rings though in a
letter to his editor in december 1939 he
wrote that he feared that the story was
growing too large this wasn't a fleeting
feeling either in a letter to his son
five years later he reiterated i'm
afraid i have made a great mistake in
making my sequel too long and
complicated fortunately for his readers
tolkien didn't let his initial desire
for brevity diminish the growing scope
and scale of the story
tolkien's writings went through a number
of huge revisions over the course of his
life while this is especially true for
many of the stories that ended up in the
silmarillion it also affected the lord
of the rings one of the particularly
egregious examples lies with the
short-lived character of bingo bagans
according to author david r collins when
tolkien first began to write what
eventually became the fellowship of the
ring he created the character of bilbo's
son bingo to carry on the story however
this wasn't much to his liking so he
changed the character to bingo bulger
baggins the nephew of the hero of the
hobbit the thought was initially that
bingo would find a ring as his father or
uncle had beforehand as the story grew
and became more serious however tolkien
eventually decided to change bingo's
name to the familiar frodo that we all
know and love
middle earth wasn't built in a day in
fact tolkien started creating his world
in 1917 when he first composed the early
drafts of the fall of gondolin and
continued until his death over half a
century later during that time the
hobbit and the lord of the rings were
published but tolkien's lifelong labor
also yielded a treasure trove of other
stories many of these were collected
into his epic myth the silmarillion
while some found their way into other
publications including unfinished tales
this collection of literally unfinished
stories filled in many of the gaps of
knowledge that had been left out of the
lord of the rings while some scenes in
peter jackson's movies might seem like
elaborations on the original manuscripts
many of them actually find their origin
in unfinished tales from a coel door
being ambushed by orcs to an account of
the death of theodried at the battles of
the fords of eisen to the story of the
black writers hunt for the ring
unfinished tales was doubtless a huge
factor in helping to round the story as
it was translated from book to script
while the world at large may see the
lord of the rings as the pinnacle of
tolkien's writing in many ways the story
ended up being more of a bother to the
author than anything else in a letter to
his publisher in february 1938 tolkien
explained that for the moment the story
is not unfolding i squandered so much on
the original hobbit which was not meant
to have a sequel that it is difficult to
find anything new in that world and is
forward to the fellowship of the ring he
explains i had many duties that i did
not neglect and many other interests as
a learner and teacher that often
absorbed me and then of course there was
the rather hefty distraction of world
war ii which happened to overlap neatly
with the period of time in which he
wrote the lord of the rings but even
when war work and family didn't call him
away tolkien's greatest passion was
still reserved for his other writings in
another letter to his publisher later in
1938 he said his mind was really
preoccupied with the silmarillion while
the world clamored for more adventures
with hobbits tolkien's mind swirled with
stories such as the tale of tonuviel the
fall of the elvish city of gondolin and
the foundation of middle earth itself
bioluvitar and his mighty valar in many
ways the lord of the rings was little
more than a tangential distraction from
the real story of middle earth
from countless acting accolades to his
epic military career to his passion for
heavy metal music christopher lee was a
truly extraordinary man and he was also
head over heels about all things
middle-earth lee read tolkien's books
every year and was so passionate about
the story that when he heard peter
jackson was putting together a film
adaptation he wanted in as soon as
possible incidentally lee's greatest
desire wasn't to play sauron on the
white but rather gandalf the grey while
he didn't get to fulfill that particular
dream his presence as a seasoned tolkien
expert was invaluable for the film's
cast and crew while some actors came
into the project still playing catch-up
with the source material lee's annual
return to middle-earth ensured that he
knew exactly where the story was going
at all times he also had the
distinguished honor of being the only
person on the entire set that actually
had met tolkien in person decades
earlier lee had run into the author
while visiting the eaglewood child one
of tolkien's favorite watering holes
while viggo mortensen's portrayal of
aragorn has been stamped on the hearts
and minds of middle earth fans the actor
was actually nowhere to be seen when the
camera started rolling instead it was
none other than stort townsend who
initially took on the role of aragorn
however a mere three days into filming
townsend left the project and mortensen
was quickly tapped to replace him as the
dust settled it became clear that the
switch simply had come about because
townsend was too young to play the
fearless king in exile a feeling that
according to jackson townsend himself
shared that didn't make matters easy for
the incoming mortensen though he had
never read the books before that point
and he was jumping into a key role next
to actors that had been prepping for
months one thing he had going in his
favor though was that he was already
familiar with many of the old norse
sagas that had originally inspired
tolkien luckily things worked out in the
end and mortensen delivered an aragorn
for the ages
while ian holm is lovingly remembered
for his portrayal of bilbo in both the
lord of the rings and certain scenes in
the hobbit trilogy playing hobbits was
actually old hat for the veteran actor
long before he ever set foot on any of
jackson's sets in fact holm's
middle-earth debut actually came in the
form of a much younger character none
other than bilbo's younger cousin frodo
holm was cast as the ring bearer and a
bbc radio broadcast of the lord of the
rings in 1981 while the radio broadcast
was a nice way to get his oversized
hairy hobbit feet wet however there's no
doubt that he ratcheted things up a
notch when he joined jackson's mammoth
cinematic production
most people are familiar with peter
jackson's iconic lord of the rings
trilogy but more savvy fans will know
that they aren't the first film
adaptation of tolkien sega in 1978
animator ralph bakshi directed a lord of
the rings film that brought the
fellowship of the ring and part of the
two towers to life on the big screen
while the film did quite well with
audiences bringing in tens of millions
of dollars and the grand scheme of
things it didn't capture the sega quite
as thrillingly as the jackson films that
followed two decades later back she
himself however disagrees in a 2002
interview he scoffed at the idea of
watching jackson's adaptation wondering
who needs the aggravation jackson
clearly used bakshi's animation as
inspiration for many shots in his own
film too in fact she wasn't happy about
this either pointing out that it wasn't
properly acknowledged in the films while
jackson had denied it had any bearing on
the issue until later one thing the two
directors had in common however is a
true love of the source material fact
she says the books are absolutely
perfect there isn't a sellout moment in
them the characters in setting are
staggering nothing like it in fantasy
can touch it
in an era when motion capture characters
have become as commonplace as they are
breathtakingly realistic it's easy to
forget one of the greatest breakthroughs
in mocap history gollum peter jackson
and company faced a huge challenge when
it came to adapting smeagol to the
silver screen he was integral to the
storyline required a lot of close-up
screen time and was practically buck
naked too so you couldn't settle for
good facial expressions and throw an
overcoat over the character to hide the
rest weta digital the new zealand-based
company co-founded by jackson brought
gollum to life and the lord of the rings
trilogy as well as the hobbit films that
followed but while they were focused on
the technical aspects of the job what
they really needed was an actor
brilliant enough to play the character
on the set enter andy serkis who
delivered a performance for the ages as
he acted out many of golem scenes while
covered from head to toe in motion
capture gear the mingling of weta
digital and circus was magical to say
the least delivering one of the first
truly believable motion capture
performances in cinema history
[Music]
it was a benchmark and an inspiration
that spurred the development of
countless other characters including
marvel's thanos and caesar from rise of
the planet of the apes the latter of
whom it's worth pointing out was also
played by circus
peter jackson is inextricably linked to
the lord of the rings and he will be for
a long long time even amazon's grand
plans for a series set in middle earth
couldn't get started without him with
rumors suggesting that amazon had made
at least some effort to incorporate
jackson's vision into their new project
however before jackson there were the
beatles yes the fab four actually tried
to get the rights to make the lord of
the rings films themselves and they
didn't just want to produce them they
wanted to star in them as well paul
mccartney would play frodo george
harrison would play gandalf ringo starr
was to be sam and john lennon would be
gollum they wanted to use original songs
in the production and even approached
stanley kubrick to direct perhaps
unsurprisingly tolkien put an end to
that particular adaptation before it
could ever really begin
j.r.r tolkien's most famous works take
place in the third age of middle earth
and the author has expanded on the
history of his legendarium elsewhere but
what about the years after the end of
the war of the reign just what happened
in middle earth's fourth age
if you want to properly understand the
fourth age it's important to get a good
idea of what led up to it the first
stage begins when the dark lord morgoth
sneaks into the realm of valinor steals
the one-of-a-kind jewels known as the
silmarils and hightails it back to
middle earth looking for revenge a
faction of elves set out in pursuit of
their enemy these elves spend the next
500 years waiting war against morgoth
they win some early victories but over
time the dark lord regains the
initiative and eventually utterly
overwhelms the elves and their mortal
allies the free peoples are only saved
from defeat when aragorn's ancestor e
arendelle sails back to the blessed
realm and asks the godlike valar for
help this leads to the catastrophic war
of wrath in which morgoth is overthrown
his servants are scattered and vat
swaths of middle earth are drowned
beneath the sea
the second age is defined by a rise of a
new dark lord morgos chief lieutenant
sauron this age is peaceful at first as
the remaining elves resettle in their
new homes in the eastern regions of
middle earth and men continue to
populate the continent off the coast
some of these men found the island
kingdom of numenor eventually sauron
makes his return to middle earth
disguised as an elf named anatar he
helps the elves forge rings of power and
then creates his own ring in secret to
control them when this backfires on
sauron he declares war on the elves and
redistributes most of the elvish rings
to races he can more easily control one
ring to rule them all
sauron nearly succeeds in conquering all
the middle earth but when he is
confronted by the full might of numenor
he willingly surrenders himself to them
sauron however has a plan taken back to
the island nation the dark lord corrupts
its king and many of its people and
eventually convinces them to invade
valinor and take on the valar themselves
this goes pretty badly to say the least
and numenor itself is sunk beneath the
sea as a result one faction of
uncorrupted numenoreans survives however
and settle two kingdoms on the mainland
gondor and arnor when sauron arrives
back on the continent and begins to stir
up trouble again these two kingdoms join
forces with the elves together they
march on mordor defeat sauron's armies
and cut the ring from the dark lord's
hand
for the first millennium of the third
age middle earth is at peace around a
thousand years into the third age the
valar send the five wizards to middle
earth to help guide the free folk in
their struggle against evil around the
same time the forces of sauron begin to
muster the kingdoms of gondor and arnor
are involved in a number of conflicts
over the ensuing years arnor is
eventually destroyed in a war against
the witch king and gondor loses its own
king leading to the long rule of the
stewards the shire is also founded about
halfway through the third age rohan is
settled 900 years later and after that
sauro mon settles down in eisenguard and
starts to break bad meanwhile the
dwarves unleash the balrog and moria
duke it out with the orcs of the misty
mountains and fight a war against
morgoth's dragons that eventually leads
to smaug attacking the lonely mountain
to top all the drama off the one ring is
eventually rediscovered leading to the
war the ring and the final destruction
of sauron
the fourth age begins with the end of
the war of the ring the specific date of
the beginning of the age is the source
of some contention but in the appendix
to the return of the king at least it's
officially recorded that this age begins
when the keepers of the three elven
rings that is elrond galadriel and
gandalf set sail for valinor
this for the record is september 29th of
the 30th and 21st year of the third age
in a timeline toll keen provided in the
appendix to the return of the king he
writes frodo and bilbo depart oversea
with the three keepers the end of the
third age with the departure of the
three rings from middle earth the
kingdoms of men find their true place in
the world this new order is predicted by
gandalf and the return of the king which
he tells the ancient ant tree beard
the new age begins and in this age it
may well prove that the kingdoms of men
shall outlast you fain gorn my friend
the definitive event of the early fourth
age is the coronation of aragorn as a
ruler of gondor and arnor let us
together rebuild this world
that we may share in the days of peace
the name ellisar the new king becomes
protector of a huge portion of middle
earth and proceeds to rule over his new
realm for an incredible 120 years during
this time he declares the shire a free
region under his protection and gives
most of sauromon's former domain to the
ants aragorn also makes a steward
faramir the prince of ethilian faramir
becomes one of aragorn's chief generals
and in a letter later in life tolkien
even explained that the king made
ferramir the lead counselor of his chief
advisory group known as the great
council of gondor aragorn also remains
close with eomer who rules as the king
of rohan for 65 years
these brothers at heart renew the oath
of aorl swearing to come to one
another's aid when needed in the return
of the king tolkien writes that they
fight together often because for those
sauron has passed the hatreds and evils
that he bred had not died and the king
of the west had many enemies to subdue
aragorn and arwen marry just before the
beginning of the fourth age they
proceeded to rule happily for over a
century and the queen gives birth to a
son named eldarian and a number of
daughters 120 years into the fourth age
at the ripe old age of 210 years old
king elasar finally dies however he
doesn't pass in his sleep nor is he
killed in battle instead aragorn
willingly gives up his spirit before he
becomes old and broken it is also
explained that after aragorn's death
arwen went forth from the house and the
light of her eyes was quenched and it
seemed to her people that she had become
cold and grey as nightfall and winter
that comes without a star the queen then
bids farewell to her children and
travels to la florian all the elves have
left the golden wood by this point but
she wanders through the empty land
nonetheless eventually she lies down to
rest in the same spot where she and
aragorn had become engaged long before
there she quietly dies and it's said
that her green grave will remain until
the world is changed in gondor eldarian
becomes king and in a letter written in
1972 tolkien briefly mentioned that his
reign lasts for roughly a century i
thought i'd die fighting side by side
with a mouth
what about side by side with a friend
after sauron is defeated and the war of
the ring comes to an end legolas and
gemly stay pretty busy on their way home
from war these newfound friends first
visit the ensign veingorn and then
aglarond the glittering caves hidden
behind homes deep afterwards gimli
returns to the lonely mountain only to
find that the war of the ring has
devastated the whole region eventually
he gathers some of his fellow dwarf folk
and they settle down in aglarond kimley
himself leads the dwarven colony
becoming the lord of the glittering
caves this relocation puts gimli close
to ministerith and the return of the
king states he and his people did great
works in gondor and rohan of particular
note they fixed the gates of ministerith
which the witch king's army had smashed
forging the replacement parts out of
steel and mithril lego loss does his
part to back up aragorn's fledgling new
kingdom too and brings elves from
merkwood to settle an ethylene after
aragorn dies however lego loss finally
follows the calling of his kind and
takes a ship across the sea for valinor
interestingly tolkien claims that
because of their one of a kind
friendship gemly is also given
permission to travel with his elven
friend to the otherworldly realm the
shire remains a bustling center of rural
activity during the fourth age and sam
mary and pippin are at the heart of the
action sam and rose have 13 children and
their daughter goldilocks ends up
marrying pippin's son faramir sam
inherits begin finishes writing the red
book that bilbo and frodo had worked on
and has elected the mayor of the shire's
unofficial capital michael delving for
seven consecutive terms pippin remained
a knight of gondor and also becomes the
took and thane both important leadership
positions in his family and the shire
respectively mary becomes the master of
buckland a small colony settled long
before by his family just outside of the
borders of the shire eventually rose
dies and legend states that sam the last
of the ring bearers actually follows his
master west to the undying lands a
couple of years later the elderly mary
and pippen leave the shire and head
south they eventually die in gondor
where they are laid to rest next to
aragorn
details regarding the fourth age are
hard to come by especially after the
first couple of centuries however it
seems clear that by this point in the
timeline the age of men has truly dawned
the first and second ages had been
dominated by the elves and the dwarves
while the third age had seen men slowly
rise to prominence by the fourth age
however the elves and dwarves are
clearly on the way out and men are on
the up and up in the prologue to the
fellowship of the ring it's explained
that some of the high elven folk remain
in middle earth for a time led by
elrond's sons and eventually joined by
galadriel's husband keleborn while it
isn't known when kelleborne finally
sails to the blessed realm when he does
go he takes with him the last living
memory of the outer days and
middle-earth the dwarves remain in
middle-earth however and judging from
gambling's colonization efforts even
appear to expand their dominions for a
time nevertheless they do slowly drift
out of sight out of mind and eventually
right out of middle earth's history
aside from the lord of the rings and the
hobbit most of the middle-earth material
that we have today was published by
j.r.r tolkien's son christopher tolkien
after his father's death this wasn't for
the elder tolkien's lack of dedication
to his world though it was more the
result of a deep set perfectionism that
held the great author back from
publishing much other material
nevertheless tolkien did try to publish
more middle-earth stories during his
lifetime including a sequel to the lord
of the rings called the new shadow the
story appeared to be set a century or so
after aragorn's death placing it well
into the fourth age the concept toyed
with a resurgence of evil and middle
earth long after the events of the word
of the ring had become ancient history
however tolkien never got more than a
handful of pages into the story before
he gave up in a letter written in 1964
he referred to the project as both
sinister and depressing adding that it
had the making of a thriller but that it
was alas simply not worth doing
tolkien's letters are an important
source of information for fans of
middle-earth as the author used them to
reveal more about middle-earth's long
and complex history in one of those
letters the author provides a hint as to
when he personally believed the fourth
age ended or at least how it fits into
the world's larger history in this
letter tolkien points out that he
imagines the 20th century to exist
roughly 6 000 years after the third age
he initially states that this could put
us somewhere around the end of the fifth
age judging from the approximate lengths
of the second and third ages however he
also clarifies they have i think
quickened and i imagine we are actually
at the end of the sixth age or in the
seventh while nobody can be sure the
exact timeline of the fourth age it is
clear that at one point the future of
tolkien's world becomes the distant past
of our own
from armies of dragons to tragic heroes
legions of balrogs massive wars foul
treachery and a trio of super-powered
gems that make the one ring feel like
your great-grandmother's pearl necklace
here are the epic events that shaped the
first age of tolkien's middle earth
the first age comes on the heels of the
years of the lamps and the years of the
trees the years of the lamps lasts for
millennia and finds the valar the spirit
guardians of middle earth
squaring off against the dark lord
morgoth whose second in command sauron
will be the scourge of the third age
this world shaken conflict leads to the
years of the trees which starts after
the valor withdrawal to the blessed
realm here two mighty glowing trees take
turns illuminating the continent in the
following millennia the elves awaken for
the first time fearing for the safety of
these new creatures the valar defeat and
capture morgoth and encourage the elves
to come and live with them in the west
many elves heed the call while others
remain in middle earth the next few
thousand years are a time of peace as
margot serves a three age long prison
sentence and the elves that went west
flourish in the blessed realm it's at
this early date that both galadriel and
feyenoord were born
with some help from shelob's distant
mother mongolians morgoth destroys the
two trees and hightails it back to
middle earth where many of his servants
including sauron have been hiding on his
way out of the blessed realm morgoth
kills theoner's father and steals the
silmarils artifacts even more sacred
than the light of arendelle the
silmarils are jewels that contain the
living lights of the destroyed trees in
the fallout from morgoth's betrayal
feyenoord rallies his elves known as the
noldor and convinces most of them to
disobey the valor and leave the blessed
realm to reclaim the jewels this
rebellion is cast in disarray when
fanart convinces a loyal subsection of
his people to attack other elves as they
leave seizing their boats to sail back
across the sea to middle-earth
as fanner sails back to middle-earth
with a handful of the noldor the
majority of the elves are left to find
their own way on foot this group which
includes galadriel didn't participate in
seizing the boats they decide to head
into the frozen north and cross the
water at a path where the two continents
are closer together
roughly marking the beginning of the
first age the noldar elves arrive in
middle earth this is also the moment
when the valor saddened by the rebellion
of the elves still showed their support
for them by launching the sun and the
moon into the sky to replace the light
of the two trees
in the eastern regions men awaken while
it will take centuries for them to make
their way to the elves they exist and
they'll eventually wander right into the
first age action
out of the
the smaller group of noldor returned to
middle earth catching morgoth by
surprise the villain has set up shop in
his fortress
known as angband morgoth's seat of power
is even more foreboding than saurons
unprepared for an attack by the elves
morgoth's forces are decimated despite
morgoth's resounding defeat feanor is
mortally wounded by a balrok a tough foe
for even the mighty gandalf after a
75-year pause in the battle morgoth
attacks again but like sauron after him
faces defeat at the hands of the elves
emboldened the elves attack is mountain
fortress known as the siege of angband
the battle lasts close to 400 years
as the siege of angband drags on the
elves that aren't fighting on the front
lines establish the hidden cities of
nagathron and gondolin this pair of
fortress kingdoms becomes crucial in
holding off morgoth while the primary
focus of the first age follows the
noldor as they build cities and battle
with morgoth over the silmarils another
branch of elvenkind is also important
known as the syndar or the grey elves
they're the elven race of thranduil and
his son legolas
initially the elves continued to deal
with occasional attacks from morgoth's
forces 200 years into the siege the
first dragon glaurung ancestor to smaug
appears still young it doesn't take much
for the elves to send him scampering
back to his master after this the long
piece begins during which morgoth
remains quiet and the elves remain
vigilant the long piece is a time of
great prosperity and optimism believing
that the silmarils will soon be back in
their hands
the kingdoms of the elves thrive
during the long piece men enter
middle-earth history wandering in from
the eastern lands many of these men are
seduced by morgoth just as king theoden
will fall under sour and spell in lord
of the rings however three clans
befriend the elves and join their cause
these men are known as the adam or the
three houses
i am not mad
the long piece ends when morgoth
unexpectedly unleashes rivers of fire
from his mountain fortress leading
armies of orcs and balrogs a now fully
grown glaurung attacks the elves known
as the battle of sudden flame the
assault leaves the noldor reeling while
the battle of sudden flame is a solid
defeat for the forces of good it does
lead to two of the most epic events in
all of tolkien's writings first the
noldor king fingolfin becomes so enraged
that he rides to angband to challenge
the dark lord morgoth to single combat
just as eowyn will one day face the
witch king alone the duel is intense as
the elf lord dodges morgoth's deadly
mace and manages to wound him seven
times despite his valiant efforts the
brave fingalpin dies by morgoth's hand
nearly 20 years after their initial
defeat the elves gather their forces and
attack morgoth in one final massive bid
for victory one of the most glorious
first age battles the battle of
unnumbered tears leaves the elven armies
in ruins and morguth virtually
unchallenged in middle earth
while the battle of unnumbered tears
makes morgoth the most powerful being on
the continent that doesn't mean his
enemies are completely defeated the
kingdoms of nagathrond gondolin and
doriath remain well hidden these
kingdoms are reluctant to resist the
resurgent dark lord in the open the
elves never fully recover from the
battle of unnumbered tears weak and
divided they're slowly consumed by the
forces of darkness
morgoth discovers nagathrond and
gondolin the first by stupidity and the
second by treachery and destroys them
both i will not stand down before any
elf
not least this faithless woodland sprite
romance in tolkien's writing isn't
limited to aragorn and arwen one of the
author's most celebrated first age epics
is a love story the tale of baron and
luthien begins when baron a man escapes
into the enchanted kingdom of the doria
after his lands are devastated by the
battle of sudden flame
there he meets luthien the daughter of
the elf king thingol and the two fall in
love however the king is appalled at the
thought of his daughter marrying a
fugitive and a mortal man he jokingly
tells baron that if he can personally
get one of the three silmarils from
morgoth's iron crown and act even more
daring than bilbo's theft of the arkhan
stone he can marry his daughter baron
departs on his quest but soon finds that
luthien has come to help him side by
side the lovers travel to engband and
steal a silmaril throughout the
adventure luthien pulls most of the
weight with her magical abilities as
they return home the great wolf kakaroth
who makes the hobbit's wargs look like
mere pups steals the semoral biting off
baron's hand in the process
eventually they hunt kakaroth down and
recover the jewel but baron dies of his
wounds
grief-stricken luthien also perishes
their tragic romance is so moving that
the couple is returned to life luthien
is made mortal and the pair are allowed
to return to middle earth where they
live for a while longer together
an epic tragedy the tale of the children
of hurun is the story of a brave
chieftain of men captured during the
battle of unnumbered tears morgeth in an
act more cruel than even anything
conceived by the lord of the rings witch
king tortures huron hoping he will
reveal the location of the hidden city
of gondolin purin is unyielding angered
the dark lord curses huron's family and
forces him to witness the destruction of
his wife and children hurun's son turin
is at first raised by the elves in doria
but he flees after he accidentally kills
a mocking elf in a brawl from there he
launches into a heroic career to rival
that of the third ages boromir
repeatedly he rises to glory only to
face utter ruin turin heads to the
hidden kingdom of nagathrond where he
convinces the elvish leadership to fight
in the open leading to the utter
destruction of the cavernous underground
realm unfortunately glaurung the dragon
deceitful as the hobbit's smog
brainwashes both turin and his sister
ninio under the dragon's enchantment the
two meet and not knowing they're related
marry and conceive a child eventually
turin kills glaurung realizing what
they've done the siblings take their own
lives
the third great epic of the first age is
the tale of arendelle the mariner
directly related to all three of the
houses of men as well as the elves
arendell is born in gondolin and flees
the city's destruction as a child
escaping to the western shores of middle
earth where a group of exiles has
settled in the wake of morgoth's
resurgent power arendelle marries elwynn
the granddaughter of baron and luthien
who herself will be the grandmother of
gondor's future queen arwen the parents
of elrond and his brother elrus who
begins the line of kings that leads to
aragorn arendelle and elwing are a
tolkien power couple arendelle becomes
famous in his own right when he builds a
ship and heads out in search of the
blessed realm
eventually elwynn joins him together
they reach the blessed realm and ask the
valor to return to middle-earth and help
their relatives who are on the brink of
destruction the guardians moved by
personal sacrifice forgive the elves and
respond to the call
once the valor received arendelle's plea
for aid they gather a massive army and
head to middle earth to face down
morguth once and for all margath has
grown even more powerful and unlike his
lieutenant sauron doesn't need a magic
ring to inflict his will known as the
war of wrath the conflict that ensues
makes the battle of the five armies look
like a bar room brawl elves men gods
eagles dragons balrogs and orcs enter
the fray in an all-out battle of good
versus evil morgoth's armies are
powerful but ultimately they can't
overcome the host from the blessed realm
facing a defeat is totally sauron's
future fall morguth is dethroned and his
armies vanquished however the fight is
so intense that it breaks the land
causing a flood as water rushes in the
region is completely submerged this
event creates the familiar map of middle
earth we know from the lord of the rings
with the land sinking beneath their feet
most of the elves and valor head back to
the blessed realm however many others
both good and evil choose to head east
here the first age ends and the second
age begins
and with it comes a new threat in the
form of margot's second in command
sauron who will prove to be an even more
powerful foe
[Music]